on
me what whatever he wants to do with my
arms doesn't matter and I'm going to be
on that one foot okay he's pushing and
I'm on that
foot so the it's not my base that's
important that's what I'm trying to
demonstrate there it's that midfoot
there but I can be in h
me so I'd like to bring that left knee
to the Y Line That's that's the toe line
just to start out with and I organize
everything up
top so that all my weight is dropping
onto that midfoot as if I'm doing a solo
drill such that if he lets go really
fast I wouldn't go flying forward they
basic want okay um you can squeeze my
arms there squeeze my smooshy arms you
feel how they're mushy okay um I have my
fingers in this shape but I'm not tense
in the Palms The Palms are very relaxed
and I'm just keeping that
shape all right the more more relaxed I
am the more that comes the more he comes
in and the more that comes out okay so
what I want to do now is my weight's on
the back foot what I want to do now is
merge with that coming out shift my
weight so I'll let it
load boom and then shift my weight boom
driving there and you're going to
eventually
shift boom
ground move so I don't want any tension
to come into my body no tension into my
body TI everything stays
relaxed relaxed and now you can
understand non-
contestation energetically so he's
pushing it's not me pushing on him it's
going going through me this is the
ultimate non-c contestation and then
same thing here it's not me him pushing
on me it's me going through him he's
pushing that hard
and